was haben wir eigentlich aus corona
gelernt zb dass ein gewinnorientiertes
gesundheitswesen keine gute idee ist bei
kliniken wissen wir dass jetzt bei
altenheim und neuerdings fangen private
investoren auch noch an im großen stil
arztpraxen aufzukaufen ja mehr oder
weniger unbemerkt das betrifft ja alles
mögliche orthopäden gynäkologen
zahnärzte radiologen und vor allem
augenärzte nach recherchen der kollegen
von panorama und vom br gehören jetzt
schon über 500 deutsche augenarztpraxen
internationalen private equity firmen
dreimal so viel wie noch vor drei jahren
in einzelnen städten besitzen die schon
mehr als die hälfte und nähern sich dem
monopol und wenn sie jetzt denken ja und
es mir doch schnurz wegen der arzt
gehört falsch gedacht laut einer studie
der kassenärztlichen vereinigung bayern
wird nämlich in investoren geführten
praxen im schnitt zehn prozent mehr
honorar abgerechnet irgendwo muss die
rendite daherkommt und natürlich besteht
so die gefahr dass
medizinische entscheidungen von
kapitalinteressen beeinflusst werden zb
bei der beliebten grauer star op ja
wenig aufwand viel ertrag es sei denn
die patienten sind so frech sich eine
zweite meinung einzuholen die erinnerung
der patienten identisch man müsste
operieren möglichst schnell aber später
reichte dann doch eine neue brille
oft ist es nämlich eine unproblematische
altersgemäße linsen eintrübung das fällt
mir ein haben sie gesehen wie friedrich
merz allerdings aussehen ist nicht
schlecht oder schritt ist plötzlich
hipster also im grunde ein eintritt star
aber es steht ihm
'finde steht wir kommen total vom thema
ab immer mehr investoren geführte
arztpraxen in deutschland es fließt also
geld aus unserer solidargemeinschaft zu
unbekannten investoren dabei gibt es
schon seit 2011 ein gesetz das exakt das
verhindern soll theoretisch das
schlupfloch als klinik darf man so viele
praxen aufkaufen wie man will ist legal
die augenarzt kette artemis hat zum
beispiel irgendwo vier betten angemietet
und durfte dann 140 arztpraxen kaufen
und direkt los mit dem verkaufsdruck in
der anderen kette traten jede woche
kaufmännische geschäftsleute auf und
wiesen darauf hin dass man diese und
diese maßnahme und diese untersuchungen
vorzunehmen hätte
das fordern diese und diese maßnahmen
sind solche die ordentlich geld bringen
und andere zu preiswert oder zu
aufwendige soll man lieber lassen auch
gern weniger mit den patienten quatschen
ist ja klar und so werden halt immer
mehr graue star operiert egal ob es
medizinisch sinn macht oder nicht so
herr sauren chronische
bindehautentzündung war das bei ihnen
die ganze zeit ein komisches rennen im
auge ja das ist ein grauer star dabei
operieren müssen
sie gerade sie sind ja gesetzlich
versichert
dem fall
reicht dieses monopol hier völlig aus
das alles in der herr der ringe die
unscharfen gefüllten
übrigens hat die große auf kauffälle
wohl gerade erst angefangen sagen
experten und leider gibt es für die
investoren hätten weder eine
kennzeichnungspflicht noch irgendwo ein
register die politik in berlin hat das
problem an sich erkannt aber macht
erstmal nichts und das ist fahrlässig
sage ich ihnen denn manchmal kann das
für die patienten durchaus folgen haben
hier eine zahnärztin berichtet anonym
von fällen wo vielleicht auch ein zahn
oder mehrere zähne waren die gar nicht
versorgt werden müssten und wo keine
karies vorhanden war
das heißt sie haben zehn angebot der war
eigentlich noch gesund waren
ja gut aber da kann man der ärztin jetzt
keinen vorwurf machen es ist halt echt
sehr dunkel da wo sie arbeitet und noch
wichtiger sie wurde natürlich von
investoren zu sowas gedrängt das
mindeste dass aller mindeste wäre
wirklich dass sich die politik endlich
mal einen überblick verschafft über den
anteil der inzwischen investoren
geführten praxis wobei klar es gehört
auch dazu für die investoren ist es ein
tränchen
guten morgen herr könig wie geht es dann
was macht alte weisheitszahn nur ärger
oder
wissen sie was hier gerade passiert ist
diese dumme zahnärztin hat bares geld
verbrannt mit dem was ich gelaber nennen
das macht der freizeit zahlen in dem
drei sekunden hätte ein profi nie
zahnreinigung gemacht irgendwas angebot
und die drei bis fünf kronen die fresse
geballert
hallo willkommen bei doc dividende unser
logo ist ein grauer stein ein nest aus
geld endlich schluss mit toter zeit
diese dame zum beispiel wartet auf ihre
wurzelbehandlung aber an der art wie sie
die brigitte liest er kenne ich doch
sofort da braucht jemand dringend eine
neue linse was sie sind investoren
suchen den neuen heißen scheiß dann sind
sie hier genau richtig bei doc dividende
wir kaufen im großen stil arztpraxen und
das dürfen wir weil uns diese klinik
gehört übrigens das ist kein modell das
ist die klinik
think big think dividende klar hat der
mensch nur 32 zähne im mund aber es
passen ja trotzdem 41 implantate rein
hab mal lügen vor
die in-vitro-befruchtung
ich gucke mir dann am besten ihre
eierstöcke noch mal an
und er das ist unsere knie arthrose
aber wir entscheiden was hier behandelt
wird
immer ein besonders emotionaler moment
ein patient liest seine doch die wende
rechnung um gottes willen
jeder fünfte bekommt dann spontan einen
herzinfarkt aber genau dafür haben wir
immer unseren kardiologen zehn prozent
teurer ist als normale kardiologen soll
der sie behandeln ja gut
unterschreiben sie mal hier und
da doch die wende denn gesundheit ist
unbezahlbar jedenfalls bei uns
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten einfach anklicken
märz gut
los
los du scheiße fährt